Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so we learned
a whole bunch of stuff about Thor Ragnarok
it's basically planet Hulk and we learned
a little bit about when the next teaser is
coming so here we go. There is a new round
of the Spider-Man giveaway going on now to
all you have to do to enters be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything.
So much to talk about they revealed so much
about the movie but we don't even have a trail
yet.
So try to address all the stuff.
Number 10: they are totally doing planet Hulk
with a few minor changes.
Now, they're I mean ...
There's no way they can do the exact comic
book storyline that will be an entire movie
by itself.
In fact they turned it into an animated movie,
so if you haven't seen that you can check
that out.
I mean really is like the cliff notes for
the comic book so I just recommend reading
the planet Hulk comic book, it's crazy.
It has great artwork.
You get to see full-blown gladiator Hulk,
just completely smash a world which is to
be confused with world breaker hold when he
comes back from planet Hulk, so there a whole
bunch of questions about Hulk's presence in
the film in whether or not they're going to
do Sakaar like what is this planet that there
fighting on that on the other end of the universe
from Asgard. Number nine: if Thor is forced
to fight Hulk in the arena that was actually
part of the Comic Con teaser they they showed
off it was just them bulrush each other inside
the arena. How did Hulk get into outer space
in the first place we haven't seen him since
the very end of Age of Ultron, we know what happened
to Thor at the end of Age of Ultron.
He returned to Asgard to seek more clarity
on what was going on with his visions like
he saw visions of the Infinity Stones.
We got that funny teaser from Comic Con worries
living with Daryl.
That's not actually what was happening that
was just like a funny mockup for the DVD of
Civil War. What actually happened is is he
went back to Asgard and is been a little over
a year.
You have to remember that the things move
in real time in the Marvel cinematic universe,
so if Civil War was like last spring then Age of Ultron was
a year before that.
So Thor went back to Asgard.
So there's been this big stretch of time where
he's been banished to this gladiatorial planet
whether or not it's Sakaar just remains to be seen, but presumably during that time Loki
hatched his plan to take care of Asgard to
bring Hella from her realm from hell and just
based on the pitch like we know that Loki
comes to earth to find Odin.
Meaning that he probably recants and like
by itself little more than he can chew he
probably doesn't want to bring about Ragnarok,
he just wants to be King.
That's all he wants. Hella is the one that wants to destroy Asgard.
So that's probably the turning point for Loki
were he's like okay this isn't what I've signed
on for so he helps Thor out, but that's much later
in the film.
So in the time after Age of Ultron, but before
we see Thor fighting in the arena there's
probably some fight with Loki. Loki probably
finds a way to banish them to this planet
far away from Asgard, so that he can cause him any trouble. Number eight: Hulk in space
how did that happen. So the end of Age of Ultron, sort of like the planet Hulk comic book
he jettison's into outer space in the Quinn
jet.
That's probably what happens and just crash
lands on whatever planet it is he's forced
to fight in the arena of.
So I'm just expecting them to be as simple
as possible with that like he fluent outer
space because he felt like he couldn't be around of any people.
He just crash landed on this planet.
But number seven: if they are doing Sakaar,
what is that say about the comic book stuff
because you have the Red King, the old power
what about his son's Scar.
So I'm not expecting them to do the Hulk's Son, there will be a lot of Hulk in the movie but
Marvel doesn't seem to have any plans to do
a Hulk movie, so they would probably save
stuff like that if they were gonna do a solo
Hulk film.
So like I said because it's been a long time
since the Age of Ultron. Hulk is probably been
in outer space on this planet for long time
just like the planet Hulk comic book he's
probably forces some relationships in the arena.
So the probably be some not so that but I'm
only expecting them to spend.
You know, maybe like 30% of this movie in
that gladiator area.
It'll be like one of the big action set pieces
of the film that it will turn into a buddy
road trip comedy the come back to Asgard smash
everyone go find Odin smash everyone again.
You have your big climax like the big final
battle the film so they'll be a lot of arena
but they're not gonna spend the entire film
fighting in the arena. So just look in the background
of shots for Easter eggs from planet Hulk
like a lot of times what Marvel will do like
when they do big crowd shots is the just work
people in enough they don't have speaking
part so you'll probably see a lot of the characters
from the planet Hulk comic book, but it'll
just be like Easter egg level. So number six: the
whole cast limitless potential for strength.
How is it possible to contain him in an arena
but this is also probably something the gonna
borrow from the planet whole, comic book he
has like a control collar it's like a little
device they attached to them.
The just suppresses his powers.
The only ways for him to get it off is to 1: either become so angry that the Hulk "hulk"
out.
They actually did that, during X-Men axis.
This is what it looks like when the Hulk holds
out like if you thought he looked crazy during
Avengers: Age of Ultron when he was over the
edge.
This is way worse than that.
So you can do that or you just find a way
to remove it by force is like having get smashed
in whatever fight that they have.
So maybe when he bites the war is when they
get that control collar off but I'm also guessing
that the Grand Master the character.
The Geoff Goldblum is playing has something
to do with this, because if you have an elder
of the universe someone with that much power
he could probably find a way to contain the
Hulk at least for little while .But number
five: what is the Grand Master doing in all
this.
So if the collector just wants to collect
things like he wants the infinity gems he
probably has his own plan for them the way
they describe the Grand Master is that he
sort of like an intergalactic pleasure seeker
like he's ancient so he just looking for really
interesting game.
He's looking for a good time.
So Loki probably contacts him and teases him
with the idea of Hulk fighting Thor is like
all hey when we set this up so that's probably
how the Grand Master gets involved, but number
four: big thing here Thor does not have his hammer,
so it also sounds like they're doing some
of the unworthy Thor from the comics if you
haven't been reading the comics the main version
of Thor became unworthy.
So he wasn't able to wield the hammer anymore
what happened recently.
Though is that he found out about another
hammer from a different universe that he could
wield so he's going after that is actually
the hammer that belongs to the Thor from the
ultimates universe from before secret wars.
So if you if you can read secret wars, you
don't know what's going on.
Don't worry about it.
Not doing that is only one version of Thor
in the Marvel cinematic universe.
There's only one hammer.
So don't worry about it is just as the unworthy
Thor is a story about the work that is separated
from his hammer, so the hammer is still at Asgard
Thor is on the other side of the universe
on this gladiator planet.
So if he doesn't get the hammer back before
he finds Odin then Loki would be the only
way for him to get around if he doesn't have
access to the Hulk's Quinn jet.
So there will be a period of time when Thor
is traveling around the universe without his
hammer like doing it slow style hammer itself
can open portals like he can travel faster
than light.
It's a little bit trickier than that's why
they kind of avoided that in the movie.
So far like thus far in the movies, he's only
use the Rainbow Bridge to travel. So number
three: that Doctor Strange post credit scene.
Now we know that a little bit more about what's
happening with the plot of Thor Ragnarok when
does that Thor seen in Doctor Strange happened
because it sounds like he's working with Loki.
At that point like Loki is either helped him
find Doctor Strange or help bring them to
Earth, somehow, so that might fall like really
late in the Thor movie after he's made it
off the gladiator planet but the big thing
here is that Odin has to be present return
to full power with the Odin force before the
big climax of the movie the big final battle
that will be Ragnarok we know a little bit
about that Hella unleashes all the monsters
of Ragnarok things are blowing apart at the
seams Odin has to step in with the Odin force
to take them all down and banish them back
to their individual realms.
So not expecting Odin to come back to like
the very very end of the film, but number
two know the big character that they don't
mention the synopsis, Thanos and the infinity
gems.
So James Gunn has been very clear that there
is absolutely no Thanos inside his movie.
He did not say no Thanos in a post credit
scene, so they could do that, because he also
said the not can it do infinity gems during
guardians to, and you just like there's so
much stuff that you have to do with the infinity
gems leading into infinity war, that they
at least have to touch on it briefly during
Thor Ragnarok, so would make sense that the
two space-based Marvel movies have some connective
tissue between them because guardians is coming
in the spring Thor is coming in November.
But as for actionable Thanos during Thor Ragnarok.
We don't know a lot about that like m-maybe a little bit of him at the very end
of the movie, just trying to use all the chaos
step in yoink the Tesseract and then move
onto the next gem I know a lot of people have
theories about the Soul Jem
maybe it's inside Heimdal may be will
have something to do with Captain Marvel's powers
they can always leave one gem for the very
beginning of Avengers Infinity War.
So the gonna do that.
It'll probably be the soul.
Jim, but number one big thing: is when is the
actual freaking trailer going to come everyone
wants to know where's the footage we've seen
a whole bunch of on the seams up.
If you are a comic con you saw some production
art.
There was concept art of Hulk getting ready
to punch Fire Lord Surtur.
There was Fenris Wolf that there was Loki
in the Grand Master watching Thor in the whole
bulrush each other inside the arena that was
really all they showed off a comic con, so
a lot of that will probably make it into the
final trailer just looking a lot more polished
was special-effects but think about it this
way there's two big Marvel movies coming up one
if the beginning of May Guardians of the Galaxy
to which is about six months before Thor Ragnarok
comes out and then you have Spider-Man during
the summer.
So will happen is is the probably dropped
the teaser trailer.
At least with Guardians of the Galaxy 2 hitting
theaters and then again when.
Spider-Man hits theaters so up until that
point up until like may when Guardians drops
most of their time is going to be spent promoting
Guardians of the Galaxy and Spider-Man.
So even though like Spider-Man a Sony movie.
And they're the ones posting most the trailers,
Marvel's kind of crossposting.
So the earliest I'm expecting to see a Thor
trailer is sometime around the end of April
beginning of May.
They can always drop some more.
Concept art like a really small teaser before
then to supposedly a Doctor Strange DVD bonus
feature called team Thor Part two. Team Thor
was that funny comic con trailer that they
released with Thor with Daryl, so that will
probably be a follow-up that will help push
into the beginning of Thor Ragnarok, so if
you ever wanted a reason to buy a DVD this
would be it.
So it'll be like the closest thing you get
to a teaser before the actual teaser comes
out.
Let me know what you guys most hype about,
I know everybody can't wait to see gladiator
Hulk planet, Hulk stuff. It's gonna be awesome.
So was can happen next is because I push an
Arrow video for this, drop all it's information that will
be the next video to post.
So Arrow Prometheus coming tomorrow morning.
While you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for new Flash trailer and you can
click here for new Spider-Man Homecoming,
thank you so much watching everybody let's high-five, I'll see you guys tonight!